la candidiasis vaginal es una afección
frecuente en la que crece una excesiva
cantidad de un hongo levaduriforme en la
vagina de la mujer otros nombres que
recibe son candidiasis vulvovaginal y
vulvovaginitis por cándida se trata de
un tipo de hongo parecido a una planta
el tipo de hongo que suele causar la
infección se denomina cándida
albicans la vagina es el conducto que se
extiende del útero al exterior del
cuerpo la superficie interior de la
vagina contiene normalmente pequeñas
cantidades de este hongo que no suele
causar ningún problema otros gérmenes
como la bacteria saludable lactobacilus
también conviven en la vagina con la
cándida se mantienen mutuamente en
equilibrio a veces cambian las
condiciones en la vagina lo que provoca
que este hongo crezca Sin
Control Cuando esto ocurre la célula del
hongo levaduriforme invaden el
revestimiento de la vagina llamado
epitelio mucoso a medida que los hongos
crecen y dañan sus células provocan la
entrada de células inmunitarias en el
tejido esto inflama y daña el tejido
mientras las células inmunitarias
intentan eliminar la
infección por desgracia las células del
hongo levaduriforme pueden evitar ser
destruidas por la reacción inmunitaria
matando a las células inmunitarias
también puede sueder que las células del
hongo levaduriforme crezcan en exceso y
no sea posible que las células
inmunitarias las destruyan esto permite
que el hongo crezca y se extienda lo que
forma una capa llamada biopelícula en la
vagina no siempre se sabe con certeza
Por qué una persona contrae una
candidiasis sin embargo es más probable
que contraiga una candidiasis si está
embarazada tiene diabetes se lava el
interior de la vagina lo que también se
conoce como duchas vaginales tiene el
sistema inmunitario debilitado toma
píldoras anticonceptivas o ha tomado
antibióticos o
corticoides el síntoma más común de una
candidiasis es una sensación extrema de
picón en la vagina y la vulva que es la
zona que rodea la entrada de la
vagina otros síntomas pueden ser
enrojecimiento ardor e hinchazón de la
vagina o la vulva dolor al orinar o al
mantener relaciones sexuales y flujo
vaginal blanco espeso e inodoro se puede
tratar una candidiasis con medicamentos
antimicóticos estos medicamentos pueden
ser cremas o supositorios que se aplican
en la vagina también pueden ser píldoras
que se toman por vía oral es importante
utilizar un medicamento antimicótico
durante el tiempo que indiquen las
instrucciones no deje de utilizarlos
antes de tiempo aunque desaparezcan los
síntomas algunas de las formas de
prevenir una candidiasis son lavarse
solo la vulva no el ior de la vagina y
no utilizar duchas vaginales ni sprays
de higiene femenina mantener la zona
genital limpia y seca no usar ropa
interior o pantalones ajustados usar
ropa interior con entrepierna de algodón
limpiarse siempre de delante hacia atrás
Después de ir al baño limpiar la vulva
después de mantener relaciones sexuales
mantener bajo control el azúcar en
sangre Si padece
diabetes además tome antibióticos para
otras infecciones solo según receta
médica los antibióticos pueden matar las
bacterias sanas que mantienen a los
hongos bajo control lo que puede
provocar una
candidiasis Para obtener más información
sobre la candidiasis hable con un
profesional de la
salud